[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je lui ouvre tout nu me souhaite la
bienvenue lui tout en baissant la tête
il me remet mes chaussettes il me
rajuste mes bottes et ma petite culotte
il remoule sur mes seins mon ou tient
gorgeant satin il rajuste le tricot sur
la blancheur de ma peau il reglisse la
ceinture dans les passant de ma jupe
puis sans me quitter des yeux il
rattache mes cheveux et devant moi sans
un bruit il a même refait le lit et et
quand tout fut bien rangé bien propre
bien arrangé il a même comme il se doit
Baer le bout de mes doigts
elle se redressa d'un bond avec un œil
furibond me traita de Dieu c'est quoui
tout en se ruant sur moi un mouvement
hardi
elle jête sur le lit et sans me quitter
des yeux elle agripe mes cheveux elle
arrache mon frigot tout en mordiant ma
peau elle enlève le ceinturon qui tenait
mon pantalon et elle se font elle se
rengorge à grand coup de souti gorge
puis elle enlève mes bottes et ma
petite
culote dans sa
hâte la
fillette n'a laissé
que mes
chaussettes et lorsque je fus tout nu je
l'ai
déboré tout
[Applaudissements]
cru
than